-We're about to play
"The Whisper Challenge."
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Indistinct whispering ]
-Whisper Challenge.
-Wow. Now, here's how
the game works.
One person puts on headphones
with loud music playing.
Then the other person
picks up a card, okay,
and reads a random
word or phrase,
and the person
wearing the headphones
has to try to guess
what they had just said.
So, you can play this at home
if you want.
Salma, you put
the headphones on first,
and I will read you a phrase.
And you're going to guess
what I'm saying.
-Okay, but, let's just
disclaimer --
not good at linguistic games.
Not good at whispering, either.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Is he talking to me now?
-You can't whisper, either?
Oh, my gosh. Nope, not yet.
By the way, who looks
that awesome in headphones,
by the way? Oh, my God.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Is he talking to me?
-No. No.
Mm? Mm? Mm? Mm?
[ Laughter ]
-Can you come closer
to the camera?
[ Laughter, applause ]
-Telenovela.
-"Salovela"?
[ Laughter ]
-Telenovela.
-Salmonella?
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Telenovela.
-"Ciao, bella"? No.
[ Cymbal crash ]
-Telenovela.
-Telenovela! Telenovela!
-Yes, exactly right.
Telenovela. No? Yes?
Telenovela.
Yes. I got it!
-I was sure you --
-No, you did not get it.
Okay, here we go.
-Oh, did I not get it?
-Yes, yes, sure, sure,
she got it. Okay, yeah.
Alright, here we go.
Let me put my thing on.
Ready? I'm ready for this. I'm
going to put my headphones on.
I'll let you know
when the song is on.
And then I will guess. Whew.
Here we go. Partners --
We're partners in this one.
Oh, wow. Alright, hold on.
Alright.
-Millie Bobby...
-"Feely poppy."
[ Laughter ]
-Brown.
-Plowed.
[ Laughter ]
-Millie.
-Billy.
-Bobby.
-"Peely porpy porpa."
-Bobby Brown.
-"Porpa pow."
-Millie Bobby Brown.
-People purple power.
-Millie -- Millie Bobby Brown.
-"Pipi porpa" pop.
-Mm! Millie.
-"Pipi porpa --"
Millie.
Bobby.
-Octopussy!
[ Laughter ]
-Millie Bobby...
-Billie Eilish.
-Brown.
-Billy pow.
[ Laughter ]
B-B-B-Brown, Brown.
Millie Bobby Brown.
-Ah, that's so difficult!
-I know. I know. Thank God
you didn't get that one.
-I love Millie Bobby Brown.
Yeah. Sorry about that.
Those are very difficult.
We're going to get this one,
I promise.
[ Laughter ]
-Give it to me again.
-Hot fudge sundae.
[ Laughter ]
-Hot bunch --
[ Stammers ]
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Do it again?
[ Applause ]
-Hot fudge sundae.
-Hot --
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, you naughty.
[ Applause ]
Hot --
One last time. One last time.
-[ High-pitched ]
Hot fudge sundae!
-Hot fudge sundae!
-Yes! What --
[ Dinging ]
What, I gotta talk like that?
-If it was food,
I was always gonna get it.
For sure.
Ooh, this is tough.
[ Laughter ]
Spongebob...
-S-Sports pop?
Sports pop.
-Square pants.
-What?
Sports bra.
-Sponge --
[ Laughs ]
No.
-[ Laughs ] What are you doing?
-Sponge.
Sponge. Bob.
-Barber.
-Squarepants.
What? Spongebob --
-Spongebob Squarepants!
[ Dinging ]
-Yes!
Yes. That was a hard one.
That was a hard one.
I am very, very impressed.
-Salma Hayek, everybody!